Speaker 1: This is a very personal story for
me.
I'm kind of getting.
But people know I'm supposed to go to a wedding
in Italy in early September.
And I've been wondering, will Americans be
allowed in?
The Washington Post is now reporting that
the European Union will be reopening their
borders to the vaccinated American population
very, very soon.
The European Union announced this morning
that they will be opening the borders to vaccinated
Americans after more than a year during which
travel has been significantly restricted.
This is a Washington Post report which says
the decision will throw open Europe's doors
to tourists, business and other travel after
a long stretch in which most of those from
outside the 27 nation bloc have not been allowed
in.
It will hearten those.
I am feeling heartened, I admit it.
It will hearten those who have missed wandering
the continent's ancient streets, as well as
Europeans whose livelihoods depends on tourist
cash.
One final round of approvals is necessary
in the coming days, but the sign off is no
longer in doubt.
The plan was agreed upon by ambassadors today.
The timing of when borders will actually open
is not yet clear, but it could be within days
and certainly by the end of June.
The European Council, quote now recommends
that that member states ease restrictions,
in particular for those with an EU authorized
vaccine.
That would mean all of the vaccines authorized
in the US would get the green light.
But vaccines currently manufactured in Russia
and China, that's the Sputnik and the Sinovel
vaccine would not, at least at this time,
qualify you for entry to the European Union.
This guidance from the European Union is not
binding, meaning a country could say we're
not letting anybody in or a country could
say, we'll let people in with the Sputnik
vaccine or the Sino vaccine or the BLETCH
injections or whatever they want to do.
But this is the guidance from the European
Union.
It has been a massive struggle in Europe.
Greece open relatively early.
Croatia is open.
Estonia, there are way I mean, listen, if
the truth is if you're determined to go somewhere,
you can almost certainly go.
And I know, you know, 10, 15 people who have
done it.
I have friends who wanted to go visit family
in France.
France was allowing people coming from the
UK.
The UK was allowing Americans with a 14 day
quarantine.
So they went to the UK, hung out 14 days,
worked remotely, then went to France like
you could do it all along.
But that's not going to get the tourism industry
restarted.
So we are seeing a definite change at this
point in time.
Now, you could you will have a situation where
you will have vaccinated Americans going to
countries where the local population is not
yet highly vaccinated now, per the CDC, although
they've not yet really changed country specific
travel guidelines, the CDC says if you were
vaccinated, just about any activity is safe,
even without a mask, although you should wear
a mask in certain situations as dictated by
local law, regulation, business policy, whatever.
A third of EU residents have gotten at least
one dose of a vaccine in the U.S.
About half of Americans have gotten at least
one dose.
So you will have it's basically six weeks
behind Europe is six weeks behind the United
States.
Given how slowly the initial vaccine rollout
was in Europe, it's actually pretty good that
they're only six weeks behind and there are
going to be probably significant accelerations
as more and more vaccines will flow in the
direction of Europe.
Now, I've said for a while, over time, the
number of people who don't want the vaccine
in the US is going to decline because they're
are going to be more and more things.
You need to be vaccinated in order to do one
of those things now that you will be able
to do a vaccinated as.
Go to Europe.
I don't know that the anti vaccine Republicans
are that big on Europe, and what I mean by
that is a lot of the same people that still
don't want a vaccine, which is 41 percent
of Republicans, a lot of them are probably
the types of people who see the concept of
Europe as sort of like sissy, flamboyant and
socialist.
And they don't care about Europe and they're
not interested in going to Europe.
And in fact, being told you can only go to
Europe with a vaccine.
It might make them more.
It might reinforce their anti vaccine beliefs.
Maybe not.
But we are seeing the decline in anti VAX
slowdown last month.
Forty three percent of Republicans did not
want the vaccine this month.
It's 41 percent of Republicans say it is a
decline, but it's a very, very slow decline.
So great news for who is this great news for?
This is great news for would be travelers.
This is great news simply for those who want
to see the world start to be able to come
out of what was a very dark winter, a winter
of twenty twenty.
And hopefully we will continue to see those
cases and deaths decline.
I am cautiously optimistic that we will and
we will all be celebrating on Memorial Day
weekend, not only with maybe barbecues, but
also with a crazy my accountant is saying,
David, don't do it.
My staff is saying, David, don't even think
about it.
My lawyer is saying I would reconsider, but
I'm going to do it.
On Memorial Day.
We are offering an historic Memorial Day membership
special, be notified of it on Memorial Day
by simply getting on my mailing list.
You go to David Pakman Dotcom, you type in
your email address if you know what it is
and you will be notified on Memorial Day,
how do you do it?
Instructions forthcoming on May 31st, we'll
take a quick break, let me know your thoughts
about the reopening.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman and we have
a really packed show for you today.
Let me very briefly remind you, lest we forget
that The David Pakman Show does depend on
the support of viewers and listeners like
you to continue doing what we do and to continue
the expansion, which will soon include a second
YouTube channel with new content.
Very exciting.
You can sign up and participate in the support
by getting a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom,
the coupon code better.
Twenty one does save you money if so desired,
but I believe the normal prices are really
perfect.
They're really perfect prices.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom